so today at the London chess classic we  have a special little fundraiser a  grandmaster is plating on all comers to  benefit chess in the schools here in  London which is a lot about what the  Grand Chester is about both here in  London and in st. Louis so anybody is  free to come and play here we've got  Grandmaster Chris Ward taking on all  comers minimum donation so everybody has  to give a little change and I don't  think there's a maximum donation a  really fun little promotional idea have  some fun playing a grandmaster and raise  some money for what this event is all  about you we've got a lot of kids in the  background probably rooting against the  Grandmaster right yeah they're not a 30  again said yeah and it seems like this  is gonna be a tight game cuz the  grandmasters not so sure how it's going  to go